[Music]
this week on brian ross investigates
the amazing story of the international
fugitive who stole
billions befriended hollywood stars did
business with goldman sachs
and set new standards for extravagant
luxury
he was probably the largest
thief that's ever existed on this planet
for leonardo dicaprio
he was a source of unlimited money for
films including the wolf of wall street
and he said look um we can finance your
next four films with scorsese
and so they put the money in for the
walk of wall street now joe lowe
is a wanted man believed to be hiding
and protected
in china do you think we'll see jo low
in a u.s courtroom at any point in the
near future
absolutely not plus president trump and
the american intelligence community
is the commander-in-chief demanding that
russian meddling in the election
be kept from the american public we're
joined by matt olson
a former top national security official
in the obama era
warning it's all becoming too political
and our winners and losers in the media
see if you agree
with the editors of mediaite and what
they say about the bombshell reporting
by atlantic magazine
and its anonymous sources i don't think
we've had a president
who has contempt for
american soldiers wounded veterans
people who've been killed in action
from the law and crime trial network
this
is brian ross investigates
good evening and thank you for joining
us and welcome to our viewers on
facebook live and youtube live
i'm brian ross joined as always by my
colleague rhonda schwartz and rhonda
forget the bank robber willie sutton
forget bernie madoff
no one stole more money ever than the
young man you are about to meet
he hobnobbed with hollywood stars he did
business with goldman sachs
and he fooled and scammed a lot of
supposedly smart people rhonda
that's right his name is jolo and
authorities say this young man became
an international uh crime spree
involving four and a half billion
dollars starting when he was in his
twenties
now he's an international fugitive and
there's an interpol red note is out for
his arrest
there's a sensational book about him
called the billion dollar whale by
two wall street journal reporters tom
wright
and bradley hope and i talked earlier
with tom wright who is based in hong
kong
tom thanks so much for joining us
tonight explain to us why joe low is
considered a
billion dollar whale and how did you get
away with fooling so many people
goldman sachs prime ministers banks
around the world
hollywood stars we called our book
billion dollar whale because he was the
largest
biggest nightclub whale that anyone had
ever encountered i mean
this guy would go into a a casino in las
vegas and spend
three million dollars on a wednesday
night for no reason and dropped fifty
thousand dollars of chips on the floor
and just lose them so he was an
incredible spender
what people didn't know about him um and
you know this was leonardo dicaprio who
was his friends
was beats that produced the music
produced really shiki's husband who was
his friend what they didn't know about
him was
all of his money was stolen and he was
probably
the largest uh thief that's ever existed
on this planet i mean he
was a malaysian who came from a pretty
you know rich family but not not
extremely rich family
and it's an extremely complicated story
but he persuaded the prime minister of
malaysia
who was a family friend via by her
school friend
to allow him to run a sovereign wealth
fund which is obviously these funds that
run
billions of dollars in state wealth and
through that role
he was able to just filch billions of
dollars out of the country
and use it to build a hollywood empire
in the u.s
it's it's just uh an unbelievable story
why did hollywood fall so hard for him
leo dicaprio
so what jolo basically when he when he
first uh when he first
took this money and this is back in 2009
he
really wanted to get to know the
hollywood stars he started with paris
hilton he
he very strangely thought that paris
hilton was a good actor and had
enjoyed her her horror films um or
horror film
so he paid he paid for her to party with
him and he worked out that you could pay
for a lot of stars to party with him
so he knocked up against leonardo
dicaprio and he
jolo worked out that dicaprio needed or
wanted
film financing because although dicaprio
is one of the
the planet's leading actors he doesn't
have
um you know he has his own production
company he doesn't have the money to go
and make a hundred million dollar film
he still relies on the studios
so jolo came along having stolen
billions of dollars from malaysia and he
said
look um we can finance your next four
films with scorsese
and so they put the money in for the
walk of wall street was all this
absolutely not we were making more money
than we knew what to do with
they made that film with them and they
were going to make the irishman um
before all of this this scandal blew out
into the open
what was the magic about him did he have
some gift of gab did he have a great
pattern
what did he do to influence people and
make them think he was in fact
a billionaire the amazing thing about
jolo is he's in some way a bit of a
cipher
he he just he everyone you talked to
what was he like they said well he was
very soft-spoken
malaysian guy he would pay for you know
there's a scene in in billion dollar
whale
what um 20 playmates um party with jolo
and leonardo dicaprio in
a in a suite in the palazzo hotel in
vegas and
um that you ask the playmates about him
and
they say well he's just a quiet guy he
seemed a bit shy
almost even scared of women and you
don't get the sense that he is at all
charismatic
but what he could do was bring
change people's lives overnight with
millions of dollars you know
and how about goldman sachs uh i get it
with hollywood perhaps they were
influenced by the money but goldman
sachs these are candy people
well they're very easy they need to get
well they are kenny they need to make
money right
so again this this fraud happened in
2009
and um obviously the financial crisis is
happening in the u.s the aftermath of
the financial crisis
the stock market is in the doldrums in
the u.s and and lloyd blankfein who was
then the ceo
of goldman he tells all of his partners
go and be goldman
in other places meaning go around the
world and find business
and this this was great for a guy called
tim leisner who was a german partner of
goldman in in
asia because he was out here trying to
do business
now southeast asia and east asia there's
very bad regulation
um capital markets are very poorly
regulated there's a lot of corruption
and so to do big deals in this part of
the world it's very hard to do it and to
to do it straight and so what happened
was uh leicester got very close to jolo
now goldman they their compliance
department realized jolo was a strange
guy where
he if you googled his name he claimed to
be from a billionaire family but you
couldn't find anything about his family
so goldman compliance said look don't
open a private bank account for this guy
but um leicester kept on doing business
with him
and eventually uh goldman raised uh six
billion dollars i think 6.5 billion
dollars
for the the sovereign wealth fund that
joe lowe
ran and jolo then stole half of it
now goldman's um senior management would
say well we didn't know about that
even though there were many red flags
about you know about this deal
including why was it you know 20
something year old malaysian running a
sovereign wealth fund from behind the
scenes
and what they say now is that tim
leisner this german partner was a rogue
banker
and that jim leicester has pleaded
guilty in the us to helping steal
200 million dollars of that money
through his accounts and his
his sentencing is yet to happen so we'll
still see but goldman has
recently paid over two billion dollars
to the malaysian government
in fines related to this case and it
still has to
settle in the us and um the big question
here is will goldman as a bank
have to um plead guilty um
at the state at the institution level
which of course it never did after the
global financial crisis jolo is still
on the run he is thought to be in china
you're in hong kong what do you know
about his whereabouts
well the last uh really good information
we had on jolo's whereabouts
he was in wuhan of all places um and
that that's not just gossip that's from
malaysian police have said that and our
sources have told us that that is true
as well i think he had family there
um but we don't have an exact uh
location on him right now but we're
pretty certain that he's in china
once this whole scandal came out in the
open in 2015
uh the malaysian prime minister who was
jolo's protector and also uh
extremely corrupt and involved in this
this is one reason jolo got away with it
he told him look go to china stay out of
malaysia it's too dangerous for you here
and jolo went to china and continued to
do what he had always done which was to
just do corrupt deals and what's the
latest there on the money he's paid to
one of uh
the trump campaign's fundraisers
so after he was on the run in china and
um he's being sought by the us
he's ch jolo has been charged in the u.s
criminally for money laundering and
other offenses he's been charged in
malaysia there's interpol red notices
out for him
um but there's no expedition treaty with
china so he's sitting there in china
and he tried to influence the department
of justice to get it to drop its
investigation into
into this whole matter which is ongoing
um
uh he settled with the us on a on a
civil lawsuit which was an attempt
to get back which is a successful
attempt by the u.s to get back all the
assets that he had
bought with the stolen money which
include you know uh
picasso paintings an apartment in the
time warner center
on columbus circle um mansions in la the
film the wolf of wall street the
proceeds from that all of these things
have been
seized by the u.s government but the
criminal case against joelo goes on and
he trying
he's trying to get it dropped and one
way he tried to get it dropped
um this is an astounding code to the
story
was he paid this guy elliot brody
millions of dollars or
the family of elliot brody millions of
dollars to try to influence the
department of justice to drop its case
eliot brody in 2017 and 18 was the rnc
deputy finance chair um and and the
close
associate of president donald trump um
he the washington post reported this
week that he is close to being indicted
in this matter
um and and i should say it wasn't
successful the trump administration as
far as we know is continuing to
to investigate so what's the next
shooter drop they've
seized most of his assets here in the
u.s and finally do you think we'll see
joe law in a u.s courtroom at any point
in the near future
absolutely not i mean the the the
deteriorating relationship between china
and the u.s makes it impossible for the
us to get him back
i'm not even sure it's a very high
priority for the department of justice
to get jolo um back i think they
probably
have and have told malaysia look you can
try him
because he's a malaysian citizen
malaysia also has an arrest warrant for
him
malaysia does want him back and does
want to try him but the question is why
would
china allow him to to leave and to go
and face trial when he he knows all
about
corruption in chinese infrastructure
deals he's also a pretty effective pawn
for china
in negotiations with with countries like
the us and malaysia
um and so i don't expect him to see the
inside of the courtroom anytime soon
all right tom ride thank you so much
great reporting fantastic book and i
know you'll stay on the story
hope to talk to you again soon thank you
and joe lowe for what it's worth on his
website says he's innocent of all the
allegations
coming up the russians are coming the
russians are coming
why doesn't the president want us to
know about it when we come back
you're watching the law and crime trial
network
this country's election is now eight
weeks away and we know already the
russians are once again
trying to meddle in the outcome as they
did four years ago
yet senior intelligence officials in the
trump administration
are either trying to downplay the area
or keep it hidden
all together we're joined now
by matt osid a former senior national
security and intelligence official
in the obama administration who now
supports the candidacy of joe biden
matt thanks for being with us here
tonight let me start by asking you we've
now learned in the last few weeks that
the
office of national intelligence will
stop giving briefings to congress
about russian meddling in the election
and that the department of homeland
security
tried at least according to abc news to
bury a report
detailing how the russians were
amplifying concerns about joe biden's
health
let me ask you what's the implication of
all the politics of that
and how in the first place do uh
intelligence officials know what the
russians are doing
yeah well good to be with you brian and
first of all
you know these developments are really
deeply concerning because
what they are part of is a broader
pattern that we've seen now
i think for the past three plus years of
the politicization
of intelligence going back all the way
to uh the way
uh president trump and the white house
generally um
really disparage the intelligence on on
russian interference in the 2016
election
so we now have a repeat of that uh going
into
uh the 2020 election and as you
mentioned
um you not only have uh the president
saying
or disregarding intelligence reporting
you have an unwillingness
of intelligence leaders to brief
congress
uh so you they're not going up to
provide in-person briefings on the
latest intelligence and they've also not
been willing to give the annual
unclassified
threat briefing so this is part of a
broader pattern that we've seen
uh that as i said is really concerning
because it goes
directly uh to the heart of the role of
intelligence and that is
to provide uh you know speak truth to
power
um and it's really critical to our
national security
now you asked about how the intelligence
community may know about this
uh you know i'm not in the intelligence
community more so i don't have direct
knowledge for sure but i have enough
understanding of how intelligence works
you know this is likely the result of a
combination of different
sources of information there's the
signals intelligence or communications
that the national security agency
collects
by tapping into how
leaders and others communicate who are
our foreign adversaries
but there's also the human side the
collection of information from
individuals who are well placed
and in a position to know and what we
know about the intelligence we've seen
at least the reporting we've seen about
this latest intelligence is that
there's high confidence by the
intelligence community means meaning
that
they think this information is reliable
uh and that
there is a strong foundation uh from
credible sources
to support the conclusions that the
intelligence community is reaching
about the nature of russian intelligence
in the upcoming election
we saw a lot of meddling in the last
election what do you anticipate in the
next uh
two months really in the run of the
election from the russian
propaganda arm that office in saint
petersburg
and from other efforts by the russian
government
look i mean as you said we saw this in
2016 it was
successful beyond uh the kremlin's and
putin's wildest imagination
in that election so there's every reason
to believe
that the that the reporting that we're
seeing
uh uh the public reporting we're seeing
is true about russian meddling in the
upcoming election and i can
uh i can point to two examples you
mentioned one brian
uh the reports that have were uh
that were repressed at the department of
homeland security
about uh russian propaganda on
the health of vice president biden
um and then the uh you know the other
which is
the other reporting which is related to
the reliability of
mail-in voting and here you have a
particularly pernicious
confluence of events you have russian
propaganda
saying that mail-in voting is not
reliable and is subject to fraud
and then you have the trump
administration parroting
the exact lines of this disinformation
all without any evidence
in fact contrary to the experience we've
had in this country with mail-in voting
so you actually have the administration
of president trump
uh really amplifying what we know
is a russian disinformation campaign
designed to sow doubt in the upcoming
election so there's this is a
really approaching i think a crisis
level in the united states
that we need to get our arms around
and finally we just got a minute or so
here don't all administrations uh play
politics when it comes to intelligence
you know i just think that's uh that's a
myth um i
served in the intelligence community
under both president uh bush
and president obama um as a both a
career person
and as a political appointee in the
obama administration there was a general
consistency
across both of those administrations
that national security and intelligence
was hands off when it came to politics
when
political discussions took place they
took place outside the situation room
uh in the situation room when national
security was being discussed
in both the bush administration and the
obama administration
there was no politics involved and i
think we've seen
a clear break with that tradition that
norm
in the current administration
all right matt olson thank you so much
for joining us tonight
fascinating insights great thank you
brian
and we're back now with this week's
winners and losers in the media as
chosen by the editors of mediaite
and we're joined by aidan mclaughlin
who's the editor-in-chief of mediaite
which like the law and crime trial
network
is part of the dan abrams media empire
and aiden we start with your first
winner jeffrey
goldberg the editor-in-chief of the
atlantic and a darn good reporter
who had the bombshell story about
president trump behind the scenes
disparaging americans who were killed in
action or wounded in fighting wars
overseas
here's how goldberg talked about it on
cnn
well we don't have that clip but we know
what he said how the president called uh
military members who were killed or
wounded losers and suckers uh
goldberg's reporting was criticized by
some because it relied entirely on
anonymous sources but you still felt he
was a winner
yeah so i mean this is a pretty
remarkable report i'd say it's probably
it was the biggest story last week
it certainly you know looks like the
biggest story of the month so far it
dominated the news cycle and you'll also
notice that you know jeffrey goldberg
he's the
editor-in-chief of the atlantic uh he
you rarely see his byline actually in
the pages of the magazine
and so this was a really remarkable
story he got multiple sources
uh to say that they have first-hand
knowledge of president donald trump
uh disparaging american war dead as
losers
uh as suckers and various other
disparaging remarks
um now yeah cr uh critics of of the
press
and i'd say you know fans of president
donald trump uh sort of rallied around
him and said this is nonsense there's no
way this can be true
and basically said you know because
these are all this these quotes are
based on anonymous sources
uh you can you know basically dismiss
the reporting here's the thing
most of the reporting during the trump
era has been done using anonymous
sources
that's how reporting gets done i saw
carl bernstein over the weekend say that
you know their reporting about watergate
could not have been accomplished without
the use of anonymous sources um so you
know i don't think anyone's under
uh any illusion that jeffrey goldberg is
not a top quality reporter that the
atlantic doesn't have really high
standards for fact checking um and i
think it just goes to show the fact that
all these other outlets including fox
news
uh were able to confirm that these uh
people that were in the room when trump
made these comments were making these
allegations i think shows that the
reporting is solid
now there can be a question about
whether or not forces
are you know conflicted whether or not
they have opinions about trump that
would lead them to
make things up but i think the fact that
somebody like jeffrey goldberg
is choosing to put them into a story as
anonymous sources
means that they are not just making
things up and that he actually has
faith in them as sources as do reporters
at fox news at washington post at the
associated press
who also reported the same thing about
what trump said
and goldberg says more is coming we've
got about 15 seconds you think that'll
be powerful
you know i i think i don't think
anything is going to change unless we
hear some of these sources come out and
actually say
the things that they said off their you
know on background on the record
uh so i'm definitely looking out for
that that's right
all right aidan mclaughlin the editor in
chief of mediaite thank you
so much for joining us a very
interesting story especially the outflow
and i'll continue to
reverberate this week and thanks all of
you for joining us here on brian ross
investigate
and thanks to our team at the law and
crime network for getting us on the air
and getting us off the air
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you